I'm not sure if you've ever been to New
York City but if you have and you've
been to Times Square then this video you
can relate do you want to go on a bus
tour no we played you in the bus tour
no no if it's not bad enough that
they're constantly screaming bus tour in
your face they then start throwing
flyers in your face let's go west or
west or west or west or I do not want to
go in a bus tour you look like you will
go on a bus tour really well I'm gonna
need some clarification around that what
does a person who looks like they want
to go on a bus tour look like because
it's sure is not me
silento Bosco okay then robusta they
have other tonight kind of comedies or
maybe even buy a tea shop
[Music]